[Music]
hallo YouTube just Louis and my friends
this is grunge in here welcome to the
21st episode of my chest strap series in
this episode I am going to show you a
mafia line against more oxy mine in the
Sicilian from black perspective now
anybody who plays the Sicilian knows
very well that it is White's one of the
most strong and reliable weapon it's
solid structure drain out all technical
possibilities in the position which
literally frustrates many Sicilian
players especially if they are playing
for the win don't worry because the line
I am going to demonstrate here not only
wins the pawn in the opening but then it
is only white who is going to suffer and
struggle for rest of the game the
opening arises after the following order
efore c4 Knight to f3 Knight to c6 d4 C
captures deform and Knight captures
Defoe in the modern world where you have
the access of mega database online
database and many other resources which
can tell you exactly what your opponent
is playing and if his preference is
nothing better than more oxy bind then
here I am going to propose a very tricky
move Queen to c7
the obvious choice from the white is to
play c4 and create the mind immediately
however if you oppor and continue with
moves such as Knight to c3 then my
recommendation is you play the movie six
and transpose back to the Sicilian time
mono or the pulse and volition which is
one of the modern trendy Sicilian line
okay
c4 what else so you can see I have
highlighted by the arrows white has
created this bind which completely
dissuade black somatic break defy well
no matter black is going to continue it
Knight to f6 attacking on e4 Knight to
c3 defending and now comes the cute
point behind the move Queen to c7
because black is going to deliver this
mafia bomb BAM hahahaha well as a black
in how many openings you are going to
win pawn on the sixth move the game this
is the beauty about this line now when I
check this position in online database I
found out that there are 93 games played
from this position where blacks results
are tremendous as I have highlighted
over here white has two choices amongst
them Knight captures c4 is the most
popular one but personally I think
Knight d2 be fire is the most critical
line so let's see each byte on the first
move Knight captures c4 is obviously bad
the simple reason is after Queen to e5
not only black is going to regain the
piece but asking white hey what you get
for losing the pawn in the opening okay
the base response goes with Knight to be
fie looking at juicy c7 square but no
matter black is going to deliver this
check first and after the move Bishop to
e2
black queen can simply come back to the
e5 square where it can nicely defend the
c7 square if you opponent continue here
with g3 then queen-to-be it is a very
strong reply so in the majority of cases
quite continue with f4 and after the
move Queen to be it and castle on the
Kings side yes indeed White has some
development but I don't think so it
worthy upon as per the liking you can
play either the move d 6e six and g6 and
play your favorite Sicilian and once you
consolidate your position
it is only white who is struggling to
make a draw so this is one of the
wonderful trap exists against more oxy
vine which you should definitely
consider playing in the professional
tournament to my surprise Knight d2 b 4
has been played only in four games but
certainly it is more critical than
Knight captures seafoam here as white is
attacking two piece black responses
force black has to play Queen to e5
pinning down the c3 Knight as well as
controlling the c7 square and white will
continue with his tricky business Quint
v2 attacking on e4 so black responds his
force black has to take this knowledge
and now if I take back the night then
absolutely he has no compensation but
White's idea is he wants to deliver this
nasty check Knight to d6 the forcing
line continues with King to d8 Knight
capture c7 if King to e8 then White has
a forcing draw so my recommendation here
is you continue with King to c7 and why
doesn't have time to get this rook in
the corner because his own Queen hangs
so accordingly white response his force
white has to play Queen to d2 pinning
down the c3 Knight and now black and
save his rook with
so by all this means white has gained
his pawn back but as the analysis goes
further you will find out that in almost
all the variation it is only black who
is coming out on the top here - Musa
tried the obvious move B capture c3 is
less accurate due to the strong reply by
black that is at six so you can see the
simple idea by black he wants to trap
that night in the black camp one game in
the database continued with Bishop to d3
so trying to get attack on rook black
plays Queen to h5 attacking the knight
which white defended with Queen to f4 a
check to the king so black responds his
force black has to play d6 and now the
problem coming on the surface so black
has a very simple idea to play Bishop to
e6 and trapping the night
and I think white has the only surviving
resource which I don't think all of your
opponent are going to find out and that
is G for giving up upon to save a piece
the line continues with Bishop captures
g4 rook to g1 G Phi counter attacking
the Queen
but after Queen captures g4 Queen
captures f7 it is turned out that after
all these complications black still
remain upon up and look at white Queen
side it is completely shattered and with
all aspects it this is a winning gauge
for the black the most accurate response
here is Queen capture c3 but you can see
already White has problem after queen
capture c3 because it completely
crippled down white pawn structure on
the Queen side and on top of everything
black has the same threat at 6 so that
poor Knight is stuck in the
black cam and white need some
intelligence to pick out that baby I did
this position in just one game against a
2100 rated opponent and this game will
give you a gate inside how good this
position is for the black my opponent
continue with c5 so he just want to stop
me to play d6 but I played the move g5
so my simple idea is to play rook to g7
and trapping that night so he continued
with Bishop to c4 defending as well as
attacking and I played a very tricky
continuation that is first of all Bishop
to g7 creating a thread my opponent
defended with Bishop to d2 and now comes
Knight to e5 so by force White has to
move the bishop and if he moves it then
the night will fall after rook to f8 and
position is not at all easy to play as a
white after a long consideration my
opponent come out with his blunder move
Knight captures at 6 which at first
sight looked so cool because it is
saving all the pieces but after blacks
next reply that is hooked to a fate he
figured out that he is going to lose a
piece in a broad daylight
well I hope you enjoy and learn this
wonderful trapline against more oxy mind
play the Moon Knight captures efore
shock your opponent and get some great
victories and to Naaman points well
thank you for watching this video feel
free to like subscribe and comment on
this video and I'll meet you in my next
episode very soon bye and take care